i i didn't i didn't follow any of the
sauce food stuff at all i think on
youtube i was not watching that kind of
stuff then i think i was still watching
like gameplay stuff i was like
exclusively in like call of duty
walk-throughs or something stupid [ __ ]
come on what's that stupid [ __ ] i was
into that too can we talk about
don't lie can we talk about sourcefed
anime or whatever that what was this
what was the anime show though animated
yeah i think yeah that was fantastic um
we had andre this independent animator
uh make animations of short clips from
things like our podcasts and our table
talks and they were very good because he
was very good the animator did
everything he like really expanded the
comedy
laughs uh not sort of animated um anime
club
oh anime club
[Music]
yeah and i was like [ __ ] i'm gonna be
out of this
yeah actually so anime club existed
before me
and uh mac tourney was doing it and she
kind of did it like
all these names sound so familiar but
quite like not quite i don't have
like a face to play now is like a
cosplayer
yeah and um she's like a sexy model yeah
and yeah she's doing great
um and we still keep in touch i miss her
a lot she misses japan
um but yeah so she started it and
i do believe they wanted to expand it
and it would obviously make sense if
somebody who
who like has some kind of professional
experience with anime
as well on top of like being japanese
that's kind of a no-brainer there yeah
so i was legitimately hired mainly to do
that to fill that role um and it was
just when she
was on her way out so i was like i
basically replaced her
yeah and yeah and then will and i took
it over but
it was fun but it was really difficult
because
the style was supposed to be that i was
the so-called
expert kind of teaching the novice yeah
yeah he has all these questions but
they're
so very left field that like i didn't
know how to
kind of bring it back because because i
think um you know all
you know all respect to mctourney but
you know because i remember when she was
handling anime club
um which was like season one of anime
club it's like
it started a lot of let's say
controversial opinions within the anime
community because i
remember it was the first time where we
saw like this kind of mainstream
youtuber
try to like bring the anime culture to
the wider mainstream audience nowadays
it's like pretty you know
pretty soon every brand is like hey i
like anime
anime show that was like produced by you
know philly d
or you know he had his name involved
with sauce fed and this was like the
most mainstream
anime had gotten to any youtuber and you
know all my love to make um
there was there was like some some
episodes where i said like some lines
were said well i can't remember it was
her or like her guest host
where she um where they called like i
think they called
formeta alchemist a shojo anime
i could just feel i could feel the the
like the unbridled grudge
in you as you're talking like you
remember how anime fans were back yeah
yeah
they they they saw this medium as like a
[ __ ] holy ground yeah um so
i think it didn't help as well that the
show itself was like probably the most
well produced out of like any attitude
content
at the time so it just felt like you
know like yes i do watch anime
younger generation yeah because i i felt
like it wasn't her fault it was just the
fault of just
i think the way the show was set up just
wasn't wasn't the right way to like
really embrace the medium of anime or
like introduce it to a new audience but
i'll say this like what you and william
did you
you made like it you you it was a huge
improvement right
because i i feel like i feel like the
chemistry was a lot better
but like what i wanted to ask is that uh
did you going into this did you know
about all the negative feedback that
you've gotten from like anime like anime
fans
um as a translator i was already pretty
connected to a lot of different anime
sites
so i was well aware well well aware
isn't the right way to say it i was
aware
but putting a face to the opinion is a
whole other world
and the backlash is quite scary however
exactly how you said i think people were
quite excited about the improvement and
there's very
there's a lot less you can criticize
like to a translator yeah so and also
i'm like actually japanese
so that like kind of mattered in their
eyes as well that's also like another
creepy thing about anime fans right like
especially back in the day there's like
so much more nerd cred if like you're
actually japanese that means you can
watch it without
sorry so he's like is that is that
i would argue that still exists no it
does it's certainly
right no it does it does yeah i was
trying to be like modest about it but um
but that mattered and i think that
overrode any
major major criticisms and also again i
was already in that sphere so i was
conscious of
what to say what not to say if will said
something weird i'd go to the producer
and the editor and be like you got to
cut that out
cause cause like i i i've always been
curious because you know no disrespect
to meg
it felt like you did take a lot of the
criticisms that they had gotten and
really
used that to improve the show and i was
wondering if it was like a conscious
decision
very conscious okay okay um because
so it it really was unfair to meg
because
she was the only person in the entire
building that even knew anything about
andrew so
the editors didn't know so she had to
source all the photos herself yeah i
mean
granted i did too after i took over but
there was no
producer that oversaw what was correct
or incorrect or knew the sub audience or
like knew how to like
hunt reddit for it and stuff like that
so i came in and i kind of started from
the backlog
and i was you know due to the research i
knew everything
that would make sense would maybe hit
would be bad
is wilkin understand like that was also
the other tether right like you have to
make sure that
the novice character is going to be
able to kind of follow it as well
without having to use it because i guess
he needs to like
channel people who are watching the
video that don't know anything about it
right right but again sometimes he was
so random that it was hard to be like
nobody's thinking that
don't ask them it sounds like before
they just it was the situation where
like the kid is like oh that uh the
teacher's like oh that one kid's good at
computers he can fix everything right
i felt like yeah just got put in there
because she was anyone that knew
anything about anime at all and you know
it's awful because it was such a passion
project of hers and she
wanted to do it as a fan but you have to
get technical you have to yeah yeah
especially if you don't have a producer
and an editor that's going to fix it on
your behalf after you're done like yeah
she wanted it to be opinionated and fun
and
what she likes and that would have
worked maybe now
but that was so not the case on a
platform like sourcefed so
yeah it's just like yeah it just did not
i feel like you were like
that idea was a few years ahead of its
time
in terms in terms of a talk show about
anime that could really do well on
youtube now
i feel like back then it was just there
was no way it was really hard to get new
people into anime especially on youtube
and a lot of the backlash you got were
just from anime fans right
as being like okay no we don't want we
don't want this to be the representation
of what anime fans are and now
now i just think man we were anime fans
were pretty [ __ ] toxic back then as
well
they still are they love you love you
guys but we are
i feel like early youtube they were like
next well yeah because i think at that
point again like it was like gone saying
i was like the holy grail was like this
protected thing where it was like it was
theirs and it had been like tarnished i
kind of understand that though like when
i was younger and i was
in japanese school in new jersey
when pokemon came to the states i was
like that's ours
what are you doing his name is
so i also like as an anime fan i
understood anime fans and
i actually surprisingly didn't get as
much hate especially
throughout sourcefed they were actually
very happy that i existed
so yeah i was super lucky there got a
lot of hate and crunchyroll i think it
was just
because it was so obvious that you were
just a weeb through and through
yeah yeah yeah people just saw you and
they were just like okay she is one of
us yeah you weren't you weren't right
you weren't trying to pretend to be a
weird you were a weirdo yeah a lot of
the time with these
these you know company videos there's so
much of it is like
hi guys we love the thing that you love
right it's kind of wacky huh
this thing's wacky too oh you guys this
is so wet
my favorite show fml this was a cringe
moment right guys
i was like because i wanted to give
people the benefit of the doubt back
then and there was like that
uh that thing that got uh that was in
one show and i think the other thing was
you were one of them was talking about
baccano yeah
and uh i think the guy who was new there
he said oh it's
kind of feels like a ripoff to fma right
because there's
there's uh baccano said on a train and
there's an episode of fma that said on
the train
and even even that that was like the
space bar movement for me as well
and and i just think you did you did
such a good job because this is the
environment that
you that you came into to prove people
that okay there is an actual
big improvement to this show and you did
a great does that video still exist on
youtube
sorry does that video still exist on
youtube i think c's
not on youtube
back in the day in the anime community
knows that that was like shared around
yeah yeah